le président des Mediapart est de vie
pleinel apporté plein de contre vous
pour violence vous l'auriez agressé dans
un restaurant parisien le 22 février
dernier est-ce que vous confirmez est-ce
que vous pouvez en dire plus est-ce que
je confirme que je l'agressais ou j'ai
reçu la plainte
les deux
j'ai pas reçu la plainte je l'ai appris
est-ce qu'on peut savoir pourquoi
un patron ça fera une déflagration on
rit les gens rides une scène de violence
dont on n'est pas les aboutissants
puisqu'on en parle pas et on a
l'impression que on lui laisse qui tue
de oui j'ai agressé et ça passe comme ça
ici ici plein de gens demanderaient des
saisines de l'arcome mais c'est sûr là
je ne comprends pas franchement moi j'ai
été extrêmement choqué par la séquence
je vous le dis parce que le problème
c'est que c'est hors contexte donc elle
s'explique pas et je comprends qu'elle
le fasse pas parce que c'est vrai qu'il
y a une barthèse il arrive un petit peu
avec ses gros sabots en essayant de
faire sortir un peu l'hiver du nez et je
peux comprendre qu'elle est pas envie de
le faire sur le moment où tout le monde
après on l'aurait fait aussi désolé elle
sait un peu justifiée et on sait
pourquoi elle l'aurait agressé elle se
serait retrouvée dans un restaurant avec
lui enfin il était là il était là il dit
n'est pas ensemble évidemment et elle
l'aurait voilà pris par les cheveux mais
il l'aurait agressé avant en fait voilà
parce que il est toujours dans un truc
de Me dérision mironie pas vraiment
journaliste donc il y va il va pas
vraiment il est un peu d'humour
là-dedans donc en fait c'est lui qui
place le curseur me semble-t-il au
mauvais endroit c'est-à-dire soit il va
vraiment et il lâche pas le truc il fait
pas le truc un peu adminente comme ça en
sachant très bien que elle va botter en
tout genre alors je peux vous dire la
vérité et vous voyez là tu as eu sauf
que vous allez dire il défend tout le
monde c'est son style moi je vous dis la
vérité et c'est comme ça qu'il arrive
aussi à avoir des trucs comme ça moi ça
aurait été moi la question serait pas
été la même j'aurais dit bah c'est vrai
on aurait dit badouna il va franco mais
c'est mon style aussi il y a des gens à
qui il y a des gens qui s'appelaient pas
non mais c'est vrai oui mais voilà nous
on est en direct ouais mais c'est vrai
que c'est son style et on va pas le
changer c'est son style d'animation
c'est comme si moi vous me demandiez de
de de faire de faire autre chose c'est
vrai que voilà ça sera si je l'avais eu
en face de moi Maïwenn je lui dis alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette soirée
alors c'est quoi la dérision en fait
quand même un tout petit peu de dérision
et un tout petit peu d'humour là où
parfois il faut qu'on mettre aussi
le sujet le sujet ne s'y prête pas et
soit il décide de de d'y aller franco et
à ce moment-là il y va il pose la
question s'il sait que de toute façon il
va pas y aller et que elle elle va pas
répondre à ce moment-là tu me poses même
pas la question exactement
on voulait pas polluer le film même à la
fin il dit
aussi l'avocat moi je comprends l'avocat
ah bah oui complètement voilà 100% bien
sûr
on se vante d'avoir agressé mon client
il s'est dit c'est c'est du pain béni
c'est vrai mais il a fait son boulot le
gars bien sûr
l'interview mais il aurait dû la
relancer quand même quand on lâche une
bombe comme ça elle dit oui je l'ai
agressé les gens rigolent derrière donc
déjà en plus faut quand même placer dans
le contexte c'est pas quelque chose de
drôle banaliser les agressions et vous
reposer une question derrière vous
obligé franchement quand on invité là je
suis une bombe comme ça vous l'avez
agressé pourquoi comment qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé là il a enchaîné comme
c'était une petite balle comme c'était
un sketch il est passé à autre chose à
la promo je trouve que c'est peut-être
son style mais il aurait dû approfondir
c'est un peu étrange tout de suite si
elle avait voulu dégoupiller elle aurait
dégoupiller
le public après il a le droit de rigoler
moi mon nom on dit des trucs parfois des
c'est vrai bien sûr j'ai dit des trucs
j'ai plein gage l'insulté il peut lui
qui rigole non c'est vrai donc voilà je
l'ai dit
ce sera dans complément donc une
émission de télé on l'a fait un petit
peu pour les téléspectateurs quand même
en priorité et là ils ont excusez-moi il
y a plein de gens qui sont pas au
courant du tout dans cette agression de
pourquoi de comment tu parlais d'entre
soi tout à l'heure voilà ils étaient
entre eux quoi et je suis désolé mais il
y a aussi des gens qui regardent quoi il
faut ou alors on en parle pas du tout ou
alors on explique un minimum là on a eu
l'impression qu'elle avait fait une
agression que c'était rigolo